- [Jared McCain:] I feel like people get mixed up a lot.
They think I’m not locked in,
or I'm just doing TikTok,
but, you know, it's so different.
[Indistinct shouts]
[Upbeat music]
♪ Hear me girl ♪
♪ I remember when you ♪
[Mellow music]
Come on.
♪♪
- The thing that I think sets Jared apart
is from the time he came in as a freshmen,
his work ethic—
and there's a lot of
people that work hard—
but I would say it was
his attention to detail
in how he worked.
♪♪
- The drive just comes from my main goal,
which is to make it to the NBA.
I mean, that's been my goal
since I was three years old
when I first started playing basketball.
And since I'm not there yet,
then I can't really stop working.
♪♪
You know, I'm a TikToker, but I'll
still give you buckets.
[Laughing]
[Hip-hop music]
[Indistinct chatter]
Why would you leave me open?
[Hip-hop music]
[Indistinct chatter]
[Cheering]
Peach Jam is when I feel
like I blew up the most.
I was, you know,
combining with the TikToks
before every game.
♪ Yeah, I'm in New York counting shmoney ♪
♪ Yeah, ain’t the stuntman,
but I'm stuntin' ♪
♪ It's eight o'clock in the morning ♪
♪ Now I'm entering my bed ♪
Here, here, here.
[Laughing]
Yeah, you can't mess it up, JJ.
I wrote down my goals for Peach Jam
and I achieved every single one.
We won Peach Jam and I
averaged 20, five and five.
So I was able to just do
what I can do and show out,
and I won MVP.
I think Peach Jam was when I
really put everyone on notice.
[Indistinct chatter]
Nice shot, Jared.
What up, what up, what?
I started, like, really
taking basketball serious
my eighth-grade year,
training with my trainer every
day after school and stuff.
And I was able to start on varsity,
which was like a blessing for me.
And so from then on, I just
started working every day.
I would describe my game, I feel like,
I'm just gonna make
the right play every time.
I'm a great shooter.
I can, if you're gonna pass me the ball,
I'm probably going to get that thing up,
and most likely it's going in.
[Sneakers squealing]
The TikTok, I feel like a
lot of people come at me.
I think it's more fun.
It's like they're coming at you
and you're still killing them.
[Sneakers squeaking]
Oh.
[Clapping]
I'm just an athlete.
You can obviously find a
balance between having fun,
being mindful of yourself
and then just being a dog on the court.
- Our pressure needs to be
different than everybody else's.
No matter how many people
are in there or not,
we bring our own energy.
We do all that stuff.
We're going to crank it up.
Make sure we're pressuring the
ball from the very beginning.
Any questions with that?
I think his basketball
IQ is off the charts.
- Setting the screen going this way...
- If he's going that way—
- That's where I tag.
But if he's going this way. Is
that me, or is that Ramsey?
- If he's going away from you,
- Yeah, that's me.
- you'll stagger,
and then you got to recover back.
- OK.
- [Giles:] If he's not the smartest
player I've ever coached,
he's up there in the top two or three.
[Sneakers squeaking]
[Whistle blowing]
- And-1.
- He does a really good job
of understanding, on offense,
how to let the game come to him,
finding open spots.
The other teams,
they kind of know who he is,
so defensively he gets
a lot of attention.
It doesn't frustrate
him. He stays within it,
stays within the game.
And then, you know,
I talk a lot about making
the right basketball play;
he makes the right basketball
play the majority of the time.
I think there's a lot of players—
elite players—that could learn
a lot by watching him play
because he plays the right way.
[Chatter]
- They won, right?
- They don't look like they won.
[Clapping]
- Let's go. "Family" on
three. One, two, three.
- [All:] Family.
- Yeah, before the game, I'm usually just—
there's always butterflies for
me, just nervous every game.
But once you get on
the court, it's nothing.
Everything kind of goes away.
But before the game, I just get locked in.
I read my book that I
read before every game.
It's called "The Inner Game of Tennis."
And, you know, it just puts
me in the right mindset.
[Hip hop music]
- "Execute" on three. One, two, three.
[Horn buzzing]
- Mental side is one of the biggest things,
if not the most important
thing, I feel like.
I'm obviously not the
most athletic player.
You can't guard me, boy.
Getting an edge any way,
for me, was mental.
So, just knowing that I can
stay positive during the game
and just keeping my
calm, never get too high,
never get too low.
♪♪
During the game, I'm just locked in to
whatever Coach tells me
and just locked in to winning.
That's really the main thing for all this,
no matter how many points
are scored ever.
Just winning the game is the main thing.
Jalen Green has done
this a couple of times,
so just to be in the mix with those names,
it's amazing to represent California at Hoophall.
♪♪
"Soft" is really the main word they use
for California basketball.
But I think we're just really
skilled players out there.
I feel like shooting is
a California thing, too.
♪♪
My main goal for basketball—
I feel like I've already
started to do it a little bit—
but just to inspire kids
to just keep working.
You know, I'm not the most athletic kid.
I'm not doing all these crazy dunks.
But I just continue to
work, and I continue to work
in inspiring in anything,
whether it's basketball
or something else in the world.
You know that ball don't lie.
- No. 11 can come in transition,
shoot the three. The point guard.
- OK.
That's Shannon right now playing him?
- Yeah.
- OK.
That's the one who's
kind of cocky—
- "Family" on three. One, two, three.
- [All:] Family.
♪♪
- [Giles:] For Jared's future,
I think Jared can accomplish
just about anything he wants.
- [All:] Amen.
- If he were to struggle,
or if he has a bad game,
or whatever it may be,
he will turn that into a motivator,
and he will become so
much better because of it.
[Chatter]
- Overall, the event was good
and we were able to come to South Dakota
and get the job done.
Do what we had to do to win.